hey schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf arte
live heute morgen live aus berlin und
wir wollen jetzt schauen und sprechen
vor allem am morgen nach dieser
wichtigen und auch spannenden
bundestagswahl zunächst einmal für euch
natürlich die aktuellen zahlen also das
amtliche ergebnis und wir wollen
natürlich darüber sprechen wie es
weitergeht wenn ihr fragen habt oder
auch eure kommentare ihr könnt wie immer
direkt im stream kommentieren oder ihr
schreibt uns eine mail an die adresse
die wir jetzt hoffentlich auch
eingeblendet sehen und wir haben heute
bei uns im studio um über genau diese
spannende wahl zu sprechen und auch zu
analysieren chuck und ella banerjee
unsere stellvertretende leiterin des
hauptstadtstudios hier schon guten
morgen katalog morgen und dann sprechen
wir danach natürlich auch mit
politikerinnen und politikern wir werden
reden mit kapelle aus dem spd-vorstand
liebte winter mitglied cdu
parteivorstand johannes vogel
stellvertretender bundesvorsitzender fdp
und ricarda lang stellvertretende
bundesvorsitzende von bündnis 90 die
grünen und jetzt natürlich erst noch mal
zu den fakten und zwar zeigen wir euch
zuerst das wichtigste das vorläufige
amtliche ergebnis und das sieht wie
folgt aus spd
25,7 prozent und jetzt sehen wir auch
hoffentlich gleich die zahlen oder der
erste jubel des wahlabends er halt
nochmal so manche enttäuschung sicher
auch jetzt ist es amtlich seit dem
frühen morgen liegt das vorläufige
ergebnis der bundestagswahl vor die spd
hat mit 25 7 prozent klar gewonnen ein
plus von 5,2 prozentpunkte die union
stürzt auf 24,1 prozent ein rekordtief
nach minus 8,8 prozentpunkten die grünen
erreichen mit 14 8 prozent das beste
ergebnis ihrer geschichte plus 5,9 die
fdp verbessert sich auf 11 5 prozent
plus 0,8 die afg fällt mit 10,3 prozent
auf den fünften platz zurück - 23 und
die linke stürzt auf 4,9 prozent minus
4,3 bleibt aber wegen der gewonnenen
direktmandate trotzdem im bundestag
da kam der beitrag schneller als ich
dachte und wir haben die zahlen gesehen
und da jetzt natürlich die frage
anschlag unter der bahn ag was war die
größte überraschung für dich für mich
eigentlich dass es gar keine große
überraschung mehr gegeben hat wir hatten
ja im vorfeld relativ viele
unentschieden die wählerinnen und wähler
die bis kurz vor der wahl noch nicht
wussten wo sie ihr kreuz machen sollten
und da hätte man natürlich erwarten
können dass ich noch mal irgendwas dreht
dass sich die spd die geführt hat noch
einmal weiter nach vorne absetzt oder
dass die cdu aufholt und sogar überholt
das ist auch unten zwischen fdp und
grünen noch mehr bewegung gibt das ist
allerdings komplett ausgeblieben wir
haben gesehen dass alle so eng
beieinander geblieben sind wie es
ungefähr vorhergesehen war das heißt
vielleicht hatten sich einige doch schon
früher entschieden als wir das gedacht
haben und jetzt war es ja in der
vergangenheit immer so also die partei
die da wirklich am meisten gewonnen hat
und so gelegt hat die führt dann also
koalitionsgespräche initiiert die jetzt
haben wir gestern abend aber schon
andere töne gehört also christian
lindner von der fdp der zum beispiel
vorschlug doch zuerst mal mit den grünen
zu reden armin laschet der eigentlich
unterlegene der also jetzt auch davon
spricht dass er natürlich gerne eine
koalition bilden möchte wie ist das
alles einzuordnen wer macht denn da
jetzt wirklich den anfang was es da
richtig oder wie funktioniert das also
den anfangen wollen jetzt nach dem was
wir heute morgen gehört haben zumindest
mal ein ganz kleiner runde fdp und grüne
machen und das ist tatsächlich
ungewöhnlich also natürlich hat man es
auch in der vergangenheit schon einmal
gesehen dass auch zweitplatzierte am
ende eine bundesregierung angeführt
haben die tradition wir aber tatsächlich
immer so dass die stärkeren parteien auf
die kleineren parteien zugegangen sind
hier haben wir jetzt zum ersten mal eine
situation in der die beiden kleinen
sagen na ja warum eigentlich lasst uns
doch erstmal gucken wie wir miteinander
können das ist insofern sehr
ungewöhnlich weil es den 1 druck
vermittelt dass am ende die beiden
kleineren koalitionspartner ausmachen
mit wem sie sich das regieren vorstellen
können und der größere koalitionspartner
der dann ja den kanzler stellen soll gar
nicht mehr so viel mitzureden hat so
wird am ende vermutlich nicht kommen
aber so wirkt das jetzt einmal das ist
tatsächlich ein juden das scheint mir
sehr spannend zu werden jetzt nach der
wahl eigentlich fast noch spannender als
vor der waldstadt unter vielen dank bis
hierhin wir sprechen natürlich am ende
dieser sendung noch mal ganz ausführlich
über all das was wir jetzt noch hören
werden schauen jetzt aber vielleicht man
zusammen auch auf die sitzverteilung da
würde ich jetzt mal auf meinem monitor
umschalten dass wir zusammen hier auch
die zahlen sehen können und hier ist
also die sitzverteilung zu sehen die cdu
csu die union bekommt hierbei dann 196
aktueller stand die spd 206 die afg 83
fdp 92 linke 39 und die grünen
118 und dazu haben wir auch noch
natürlich die grafik wer also wie
gewählt hat aber das sind vielleicht
auch alles feinheiten auf die wir später
noch mal eingehen möchten jetzt hätten
wir auch zunächst noch mal einen ton
vorliegen von gestern abend da haben
sich ja die spitzen kandidatinnen und
kandidaten geäußert und in dem falle ist
es die union die überraschender oder
vielleicht auch nicht so überraschender
weise nicht zu wort gemeldet hat und
obwohl sie unterlegen es gegenüber der
spd da doch
wahrscheinlich irgendwelche ansprüche
stellen möchte und wir haben mal kurz
zusammen rein
wer bundeskanzler in deutschland wird
muss es schaffen
unterschiedliche fraktionen des
deutschen bundestages zusammen zu
bringen und dann am ende eine mehrheit
zu haben das war in allen 70 jahren der
bundesrepublik so nicht immer weil die
partei die auf 1 war auch diejenigen
kanzler stellte und deshalb ist das
jetzt die große aufgabe der
demokratischen parteien zu sehen wo gibt
es die größten gemeinsamkeiten
ich glaube die zeit die vor uns liegt
braucht als erstes wirtschaftliche
stärke und stabilität
marktwirtschaftliche lösungen sie
braucht einen großen schub in der
verwaltung des landes bei der
digitalisierung und das thema
klimaschutz gerade in diesem jahrzehnt
die aufgabe eine ganze industrie
gesellschaft
familie ist nun katja peller aus dem spd
parteivorstand schönen guten morgen frau
pädagogen haben katja pelé war zudem
spitzenkandidatin der spd in sachsen
anhalt da schloss die spd bei den
landtagswahlen eher schlecht ab jetzt
gibt es großen grund zur freude sie
haben eben gerade herr laschet auch im o
ton gehört und auch das gestern abend
also schon die fdp davon sprach sie
wollen jetzt vielleicht erst zusammen
sprechen miteinander was macht denn die
spd in der zeit ich glaube die spd tut
gut daran für sich selber im plan zu
entwickeln denn eines ist ganz klar das
ergebnis des gestrigen abends zeigt dass
die spd als erste vom platz gegangen ist
wir haben die bundestagswahl gewonnen
wir haben stimmen geholt die menschen
haben olaf scholz als zukünftigen
kanzler das vertrauen geschenkt und
deswegen glaube ich sehr daran dass die
partei die gewinne zu verzeichnen hat im
gegensatz zu denen die das nicht getan
haben dann hier auch die bundesregierung
bilden wird und das auch mit starken
partner jetzt hat die fdp im vorfeld
signalisiert ihnen wäre am liebsten
jamaika-koalition wir wollen sie denn
jetzt die fdp überzeugen dann doch
vielleicht lieber mit ihnen koalition
einzugehen ich glaube tatsächlich dass
der wahlkampf gezeigt hat dass die spd
eine klare antwort hat wie man
zukunftsfähigkeit in deutschland sichern
kann die wir es schaffen die größte
herausforderung seit vielen vielen
jahrzehnten zu meistern nämlich
industriepolitik mit klimaschutzpolitik
zu verbringen es geht nicht nur darum zu
sagen müssen etwas gegen den klimawandel
tun sondern braucht auch einen konkreten
plan wie das gelingen kann den hat olaf
scholz den hat die spd deshalb glaube
ich auch die fdp wird sehen dass es gut
dass mit uns zusammenzuarbeiten und
diesen plan umzusetzen
jetzt vielleicht in der basis der spd
auch nicht jeder vielleicht begeistert
von den ideen der fdp also wie will man
dann vielleicht auch die eigenen leute
in der partei überzeugen dass das jetzt
eine gute idee ist eine koalition
einzugehen da gibt es auch kritische
stimmen dass das ist so und die wird es
auch immer geben egal wie koalition
aussehen das auch gut so mit mein
innerparteilich auch über die sachen
diskutieren kann aber koalitionen das
ist die minute in der relativ stunde in
der demokraten kompromisse finden und
das land insgesamt zusammenzubringen und
voranzubringen und deswegen glaube ich
tatsächlich dass wir jetzt abwarten
müssen wie die parteien sich entscheiden
wie die gespräche laufen und nachher
welches ergebnis möglicherweise im raum
steht und darüber muss immer wieder neu
diskutiert werden
und jetzt ist auch die erhöhung des
mindestlohns das war immer so ein
kernprojekt von olaf scholz also das
wird ihm besonders wichtig seien was
wird dann aber noch eine bedingung für
sie jetzt als spd sein wenn sie sich da
zusammen tun möchten ich glaube
tatsächlich dass wir im wahlkampf sehr
stark gemacht haben wofür wir stehen der
mindestlohn ist zum beispiel so ein
thema ist ganz klar dass wir uns dafür
einsetzen dass das unser ziel ist das
auch zu erreichen
genauso wie andere wichtige themen
insbesondere beim schutz des klimas die
innovation voranzutreiben stärker zu
werden bei dem aktiven part gegen den
klimawandel und wird es viele punkte
geben die dann im detail gesprochen
werden müssen und da will ich jetzt
nicht vorgreifen heute tagen ja erstmal
die gremien auch der spd und dort wird
auch erst mal auf die wahl geschaut und
auf die nächsten schritte darüber wollen
wir gleich zum abschluss auch noch kurz
sprechen aber jetzt haben wir erstmal
rein in einen aktuellen ton von gestern
abend von olaf scholz
die industrielle modernisierung
deutschlands als das was wir machen
müssen um den menschengemachten
klimawandel aufzuhalten
handelt im wesentlichen von
privatwirtschaftlichen investitionen das
ist nicht neu ich habe immer wieder
darauf hingewiesen wenn einige meinten
man müsste die regeln des grundgesetzes
auf verändern die wir heute haben für
ein ordentliches wirtschaften dass das
meiste worum es jetzt geht
privatwirtschaftliche investitionen sind
also zum beispiel der ausbau der
windkraft auf hoher see der ausbau der
windkraft an land das stromnetz die
solarenergie das was wir brauchen wenn
der investitionen in der stahlindustrie
der chemieindustrie sehen beim zement
beim maschinenbau automobilbau das sind
privatwirtschaftliche investitionen und
für das was dann noch notwendig ist sind
in der finanzplanung erhebliche
investitionsmittel vorgesehen und zwar
der finanzplanung die jetzt schon von
der bundesregierung auf den weg gebracht
frau keller wir haben von olaf scholz
und von ihnen gehört was da also jetzt
wichtig ist haben heute vorstandssitzung
was ist denn jetzt genau der fahrplan
und wann sind sie also spreche ich wann
wissen wir mehr ich glaube tatsächlich
man muss heute die gremiensitzungen erst
einmal abwarten aber spreche ich glaube
ich ist die spd schon jetzt wir haben
erschließt die letzten wochen für unsere
themen wahlkampf gemacht aber es geht
jetzt natürlich um die internen
abstimmung über die nächsten schritte
und dafür muss man die sitzung ist erst
mal abwarten vielen dank katja perle von
der spd an dieser stelle
und im vorfeld dieser sendung haben wir
auch mit der cdu natürlich gesprochen
mit wiebke winter die sich jetzt gerade
im zug befindet auf dem weg zur
vorstandssitzung und wir konnten sie
kurz vor dieser sendung kurz bevor sie
in den zug gestiegen erst noch erreichen
wir haben einen kopf an kopf rennen
gesehen bei dieser bundestagswahl
wir können als cdu nicht zufrieden sein
mit dem ergebnis unser anspruch ist es
mit abstand stärkste kraft zu werden
das haben wir nicht geschafft wir werden
darüber jetzt sprechen beim
bundesvorstand wir werden schauen wir
weiter machen aber wir stehen das
gemeinsam durch wir als cdu familie
und wer es nicht aber vielleicht besser
in die opposition zu gehen als ich jetzt
von einer wirklich gestärkten spd da die
inhalte abnehmen zu lassen
mir ist es wichtig dass deutschland in
den nächsten vier jahren gut regiert
wird und das wird es aus meiner sicht am
besten mit einer cdu-geführten regierung
jetzt müssen wir schauen was die
sondierungs- und vielleicht
koalitionsgespräche bringen ich bin nach
wie vor ein großer fan einer
jamaika-koalition
christian lindner hatte gestern
angedeutet vorgeschlagen eigentlich
sogar dass er am liebsten zuerst dann
vielleicht mit den grünen jetzt mal
reden würde bevor er jetzt mit ihnen
spricht finden sie das klug wenn das
jetzt so die reihenfolge wäre ich habe
selber noch nie mitgemacht bei
koalitionsverhandlungen von daher ist
mein wissen da begrenzt was es angeht
aber wenn sich fdp und grüne erst mal
absprechen wollen sollen sie es meiner
meinung oder sollen sie meiner meiner
meinung nach gerne machen mir ist es
wichtig dass zum schluss eine jamaika
koalition zustande kommt das ist auch
etwas was ich wirklich nicht mit zu
entscheiden habe
und haben sie jetzt schon mitgekriegt im
hintergrund gibt es jetzt irgendwie
machtkämpfe zu befürchten in der union
weil es ja wirklich ein historisch
schlechtes ergebnis was sie da leider
eingefahren haben ich fahre jetzt erst
mal nach berlin wir werden das ergebnis
besprechen wir stehen als union jedoch
immer zusammen wir sind eine familie
und wir werden auch durch gute wie durch
schlechte zeiten gemeinsam gehen und
schauen was heute im bundesvorstand
passiert sie haben es angesprochen sie
fahren da hin womit kann man aber
rechnen also was wird vielleicht heute
wirklich schon besprochen und
entschieden ich glaube die wählerinnen
und wähler die haben viele fragen im
kopf was ist der zeitplan also was
könnte heute dann wirklich schon
besprochen werden ganz konkret wir
werden über das ergebnis sprechen wir
werden schauen wo wir stärken hatten was
vielleicht faktoren gewesen sein könnten
die zu diesem ergebnis geführt haben wir
werden das aufklären müssen wie weit wir
damit heute schon kommen das müssen wir
natürlich noch einmal abwarten die
finalen ergebnisse sind ja gerade erst
vorgestellt worden mir ist auch wichtig
dass wir jetzt hier keine schnellschüsse
machen sondern dass wir da überlegt
rangehen und das werden wir heute
sicherlich besprechenden bundesvorstand
sie haben die stärken und schwächen
angesprochen dass man drauf schauen muss
wo hat es gut geklappt und nicht die
sind teil von laschets klimateam wieso
konnte die union offenbar mit dem thema
nicht so gut punkten
müssen wir uns erstmal die zahlen
anschauen wie die wählerinnen und wähler
das auch zum schluss bewertet haben ich
wurde sehr häufig sehr positiv darauf
angesprochen gerade auch hier in bremen
und bremerhaven meine erststimme
ergebnisse auch wenn ich leider nicht in
den deutschen bundestag geschafft habe
lagen deutlich über den zweitstimmen
ergebnissen von daher hab ich schon das
gefühl dass es angekommen ist ich stehe
immer noch sehr fest hinter unserem toro
für die erneuerbaren energien das
maßnahmenprogramm was wir ende august
vorgestellt haben das ist eine richtige
maßnahmenplan für deutschland den werden
wir auch weiter verfolgen und dafür
müssen jetzt in die regierung kommen
zum schluss vielleicht noch die frage
weil sie es angesprochen haben in bremen
hat es für sie leider nicht gereicht hat
sich die union insgesamt nicht genug
verjüngt sie sind ja wirklich eine der
der jüngsten die damit angetreten ist
aber ist das vielleicht auf den grund
also ich bin hier in bremen und
bremerhaven angetreten das ist ein
wahlkreis der traditionell immer von der
spd gewonnen wurde wir haben hier quasi
werder bremen gegen bayern münchen
gespielt und das wunder von der weser
dass wir uns dieses mal nicht die reihe
dafür war die spd einfach zu stark ich
glaube an meinem wahlkreis kann man da
nichts fest machen und auch wenn ich mir
natürlich sehr gewünscht hätte aber ich
verspreche ich mache weiter ich werde
mich weiterhin für das thema klima ganz
stark in der union einsetzen und ich
freue mich auf die arbeit die vor mir
liegt
sagt wiebke winter von der cdu vielen
dank für das gespräch ich danke ihnen
gestern abend haben wir schon gehört hat
sich abgezeichnet also das ist jetzt vor
allem auf fdp und die grünen ankommt und
deshalb sprechen wir nun als erstes mit
johannes vogel stellvertretender
bundesvorsitzender fdp der mir jetzt
zugeschaltet sein müsste schönen guten
morgen
schönen guten morgen
wir haben eine leichte verzögerung aber
sie können mich hören wunderbar herr
vogel zunächst natürlich die frage also
letztes mal hat die fdp nach vier wochen
die verhandlungen abgebrochen wird es
denn wieder so passieren also wieder
eine lange hängepartie und am ende sagt
die fdp doch nicht
ja ich hoffe nicht weil wir haben ja
letztes mal nicht abgebrochen weil wir
keine lust auf verantwortung hätten
sondern weil sich eben nicht genügend
modernisierung und erneuerung für
deutschland vereinbaren ließ und ich
habe die große hoffnung dass das diesmal
anders ist aber wir müssen es natürlich
anders machen als die sondierung 2017
das war ja offenbar kein erfolgsmodell
und deshalb freue ich mich dass gestern
abend ja auch schon christian lindner in
der berliner runde es angeregt hat und
robert habeck sich ähnlich geäussert hat
das vielleicht erst mal die beiden
kräfte die aus ganz unterschiedlichen
richtungen kommen aber beide erneuerung
sich wünschen und dafür stehen weil sie
jetzt in der opposition auch waren in
den letzten jahren erst mal darüber
reden gibt es für uns eine möglichkeit
sich auf gemeinsame projekte zu
verständigen auf eine modernisierung des
landes und was ist die richtung und so
vielleicht sondierungs und
koalitionsgespräche ein stückweit
sortieren
sie sprechen die gemeinsamen projekte an
da ist natürlich auch die frage was wir
gemeinsam gemeinsame projekte könnte es
mit den grünen geben und auch da haben
wir von gestern abend zunächst mal ein
o-ton von annalena baerbock in den wir
jetzt mal zusammen reinhören
wir haben ja auch vor der wahl deutlich
gemacht dass wir gerade im bereich der
sozialen gerechtigkeit große
schnittmengen mit der spd haben deswegen
auch ein zweierbündnis zwischen spd und
grünen was gewesen wäre was er dort
einen aufbruch hätte schaffen können es
reicht aber nicht für ein zweierbündnis
und deswegen muss jetzt gemeinsam
gesprochen werden wie wir die frage
sozialer gerechtigkeit und klimaschutz
voranbringen können und welcher
kombination das am besten funktioniert
weil gerade beim klimaschutz gibt es
zwischen union und spd ja jedenfalls in
den letzten monaten keine unterschiede
das ist aber die aufgabe an der wir als
grüne diese bundesregierung gemessen
werden weil es eine klima regierung sein
muss mich weil wir grünen stark geworden
sind sondern weil das der auftrag des
pariser klimaabkommens ist
die fdp hat gestern angedeutet zuerst
mit den grünen sprechen zu wollen wo
sind denn da die schnittmengen zwischen
ihnen und den grünen gibt es denn welche
ja wir werden jetzt ja nicht am
montagmorgen die koalitionsverhandlungen
hier live im zdf machen können so gerne
ich das so sehe ich verstehe dass das
das natürlich spannend wäre aber wofür
wir stehen ist ja klar und was wir
wollen ist umfassende nachhaltigkeit das
heißt dass wir die ganzen mega trends
demografie digitalisierung und
dekarbonisierung endlich mit
langfristigen konzepten angehen und wir
glauben dass das am besten geht mit
einer kombination aus marktwirtschaft
und unternehmertum und
chancengerechtigkeit bildung und offener
gesellschaft so und auf der basis reden
wir jetzt und ich kann mir durchaus
vorstellen dass wir im ziel klimaschutz
ja durchaus absolute gemeinsamkeiten
haben und dann auch einen weg finden
bei den instrumenten zusammen zu kommen
aber das müssen natürlich gespräche
zeigen ich sag mal als jemand dem das
thema demografie und rente besonders
wichtig ist was auch sehr viele junge
menschen bewegt hat die uns ja bei den
erstwählern das mich wirklich sehr freut
am stärksten unterstützt haben da muss
aber natürlich auch vorangehen also wir
brauchen eben auch in zukunft fest das
rentensystem da haben sich im wahlkampf
spd und grüne sehr links positioniert
haben wollen im wesentlichen auch in
teilen die rentenpolitik der großen
koalition fortsetzen also viele dinge
über die man reden muss aber genau da
steht ja jetzt erst an jetzt freuen wir
uns erstmal über den wählerauftrag
bedanken uns sehr für das vertrauen und
konstituieren dann heute erstmal die
gremien und dann schauen wir dass die
gespräche in den nächsten wochen
effizienter sind und vor allem
erfolgreicher sind als 2017 für das land
denn ein weitere jahre stillstand können
wir uns nicht erlauben wir brauchen
modernisierung und müssen die
entschlossen angehen und da sind alle
demokratischen parteien in der
verantwortung
christian lindner signalisierte im
vorfeld auch dass sie die fdp also am
liebsten in einem jamaika bündnis
eintreten würde und da ist auch noch
folgender satz gefallen das rennen um
platz eins ist interessant aber für die
regierungsbildung nicht entscheidend und
danach sieht es jetzt auch aus also dass
die union obwohl sie dann auf platz zwei
gelandet ist da jetzt also ansprüche
stellen möchte wie fair ist das denn den
wählerinnen und wählern gegenüber
na wir sind ja in einem wir sind ja in
einer veränderten situation das hat
sogar noch nicht gegeben also die ära
merkel endet ganz offenbar mit einem
neuen parteien system weil im bereich
der demokratischen parteien wir 24
mittelgroße parteien haben und beide
liegen relativ nah beieinander gerade
spd und union und gleichzeitig haben wir
die situation dass zb fdp und grüne in
summe mehr stimmen und unterstützung
haben als spd oder cdu das heißt wir
haben wirklich eine neue verantwortung
und auch neue form von koalitions und
sondierungsgesprächen vor uns und der
müssen alle demokratischen parteien
gerecht werden und ich glaube der
einzige orientierung oder sortierung
maßstab kann sein gibt es eine
gemeinsame basis einer mehrheit im
deutschen bundestag auf entschiedene
schlüsselprojekte auf eine
modernisierung des landes kann man sich
da auf eine gemeinsame richtung einigen
das ist das entscheidende nicht wer wo
wie zehn prozent oder einzelne prozent
vorne liegt
jetzt wissen wir aus der vergangenheit
natürlich auch dass in solchen
gesprächen natürlich ist aber auch nicht
immer nur um die thematische nähe geht
sondern es geht dann auch gerne mal um
schlüsselpositionen um ministerinnen und
minister posten das finanzministerium
ist da so einiges was als besonders
beliebt gehandelt wird ist das denn was
am ende vielleicht dann auch für sie in
finnland an der waage es wer bekommt was
wir haben vor der wahl ja klar gesagt
während drei parteien den anspruch
hatten das kanzleramt anzustreben
zumindest haben sie den formuliert haben
wir das nicht getan weil wir gesagt
haben dass er vielleicht ein stück weit
noch vermessen aber wir wollen natürlich
verantwortung übernehmen wenn wir wenn
die bürgerinnen und bürger uns in
verantwortung wählen und weil uns die
fragen von
soliden finanzen von einem nicht
aufweichen der schuldenbremse von einer
nicht mehr belastung was geradezu
grotesk wäre mit blick auf den enormen
investitionsbedarf von privaten mit
blick auf das wachstum mit blick auf die
enorme belastung der bürgerinnen und
bürger im internationalen vergleich dass
wir für das thema inhaltlich jahr
verantwortung übernehmen wollen und das
natürlich auch personell hinterlegt
haben aber ich will er den eingang ihrer
frage klar zurückweisen vielleicht war
genau das in der vergangenheit das
problem vielleicht sollte es in erster
linie um inhalte gehen und klar sind
wenn man auf die parteiprogramme
nebeneinander legt zwischen uns und der
union dineen größer das ist richtig aber
das entscheiden habe ich eben gesagt das
entscheidende ist in diesem deutschen
bundestag haben wahrscheinlich nur drei
parteien zusammen eine mehrheit weil
eine erneute groko sicher hoffentlich
niemand vorstellen kann und da geht es
jetzt darum können drei parteien sich
auf eine gemeinsame richtung einigen
weil es kann doch nicht so weitergehen
wie es die letzten jahre gelaufen ist
ganz offensichtlich ist deutschland ja
ermattet und hat dringenden
modernisierungsbedarf
zum schluss dann gerne noch die frage
obwohl sie jamaika favorisieren aber was
müsste denn der spd was müsste scholz
bieten damit sich dann vielleicht auch
mit denen machen
das ist der charmante versuch das dritte
mal darauf zu kommen das ist vielleicht
nur den koalitionsverhandlungen in la
inhaltlicher art hier schon anfangen das
verstehe ich aber dass am montagmorgen
wirklich zu früh wofür wir stehen haben
wir ja vor der wahl klar gesagt haben
auch eine woche vor der wahl noch mal
einen wahlaufruf verabschiedet mit
klaren prüfstein woran wir eine
regierungsbeteiligung messen wiederhole
das gerne auch noch mal die kombination
aus marktwirtschaft unternehmertum
entlastung und aufstiegsversprechen
offener gesellschaften
chancengerechtigkeit und langfristige
konzepte für digitalisierung demographie
und dekarbonisierung das sind unsere
blickrichtung und unsere prüfsteine und
für uns gilt dass wir nach der wahl das
machen was wir vor der wahl gesagt haben
und deshalb ist ganz transparent für
alle bürgerinnen und bürger wie wir auf
die gespräche in den nächsten tagen
inhaltlich schauen aber
was müsste sich olaf scholz also
wirklich abschminken darauf haben sie
doch bestimmt eine antwort da sind sie
doch wahrscheinlich entschieden schon
auch ja darauf darauf habe ich nicht
geantwortet weil das natürlich gespräche
zeigen und wie wir die angehen wollen
darüber haben wir ja gerade gesprochen
klar ist und dabei bleibt und was noch
mal klar zu sagen dankeschön an bord wir
machen nach der wahl das was wir vor der
wahl gesagt haben mehrbelastung kann es
mit uns nicht geben und eine
schuldenbremse aufweichen das wird uns
auch undenkbar das dürften aber keine
news sein
vielen dank johannes vogel von der fdp
bis hierhin erstmal danke schön
grüßen
und jetzt sprechen wir natürlich auch
mit der german partei die jetzt hier
besonders wichtig sein wird und zwar mit
den grünen bei mir ist ricarda lang
stellvertretende bundesvorsitzende von
bündnis 90/die grünen schönen guten
morgen schön dass sie da sind morgen
danke für die einladung
frau lang es ist so dass jetzt also fdp
und grüne da jetzt wirklich das zünglein
an der waage sein könnten und wir hören
aber auch vielleicht noch mal gemeinsam
rein was also gestern abend noch
besprochen wurde und haben dann dafür
unsere gesprächsgrundlage
etwa 75 prozent der deutschen haben die
partei eines nächsten kanzlers nicht
gewählt und deshalb herr becker könnte
es ratsam sein dass die parteien die
gegen den status quo der großen
koalition wahlkampf gemacht haben die
aus einer unterschiedlichen perspektive
heraus diesen status quo überwinden
wollten das also grüne und fdp zuerst
miteinander sprechen in den letzten
tagen ja auch deutlich gemacht robert
habeck und ich dass diese logik da ist
einer der alle anderen anrufe dass diese
logik dem aufbruch den wir in unserem
land brauchen nicht gut tut und deswegen
ist es mehr als sinnvoll dass
unterschiedliche parteien jetzt in
unterschiedlichen kombinationen
miteinander sprechen
frau lang wir haben es gehört gestern
abend also zeichnete sich ab dass da
vielleicht fdp und grüne zuerst
miteinander sprechen können könnten ist
das denn so wer ist das für heute
geplant ich kann mir das gut vorstellen
als auf der einen seite muss man durch
anerkennen bei diesem wahlergebnis ist
es eine ganz klare schlappe für die cdu
und die csu die wurde in gewisser weise
abgewählt und sind starkes ergebnis für
die spd trotzdem haben wir in den
letzten vier jahren was gesehen was man
vielleicht so ein bisschen als das ende
der ära der klassischen volksparteien
bezeichnen kann also die vorstellung von
es gibt eine partei die hier ungefähr 30
bis 40 prozent hatten dann noch ein
bisschen zugeordnete parteien das hat
sich den letzten jahren aufgelöst und
das sieht man auch in diesem
wahlergebnis das heißt es funktioniert
nicht mehr das klassische prinzip von
einfach eine entscheidet lädt ein und
dann zack springen die anderen das heißt
in der hinsicht kann es natürlich
spannend zahlen auch für uns mit der fdp
zu sprechen die unterschiede dabei
insbesondere die soziale gerechtigkeit
gibt sind aber natürlich riesig und dies
sind mehr mit der spd jetzt zentrales
thema außerdem natürlich der klimaschutz
also können sie sich vorstellen dass mit
union und fdp mehr klimaschutz geht als
mit spd und fdp nein das kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen weil ich glaube am ende
wird die entscheidende frage sein regeln
wir es über den preis oder regeln wir es
über einen mix aus preis ordnungsrecht
investitionen in vereinen den preis
gehen das ist der vorschlag der fdp und
in teilen auch der cdu uwe cdu sich
nicht so richtig entscheiden konnte ob
es überhaupt ein vorschlag habt oder
nicht dann wird es massiv sozial
ungerecht weil ich am ende dafür sorge
dass bestimmte dinge teurer werden
menschen dann gerade im ländlichen raum
sich zwar nicht mehr leisten können auto
zu fahren oder coop schwieriger leisten
können aber es gibt noch keine
alternative ist wurde da noch im bus
noch keine bahn geschaffen ich glaube da
brauchen wir klare investitionen auch
mit einer veränderung der schuldengrenze
mit einem missionsland und da brauchen
wir ein klares ordnungsrechtlichen
rahmen es gibt ja auch noch andere
themen wo sie sich vielleicht im zweifel
unser uneins seien könnten also zum
beispiel gerade auch fdp und grüne sind
sich beispielsweise uneins bei themen
wie der bürgerversicherung also könnten
verhandlungen am ende dann auch wirklich
an sowas scheitern an einzelnen themen
am ende muss man immer auf ein
gesamtpaket schauen ich glaube für mich
gibt es so ein bisschen zwei leitungen
nachdem ich auf jeden fall diese
sondierungen und auch gold und
verhandlungen danach beurteilen
das erste ist wir müssen zurück auf den
pfad des pariser klimaabkommens alle
parteien haben eben den wahlprogrammen
im wahlkampf von klimaschutz gesprochen
daran müssen sich jetzt auch alle messen
lassen das heißt wir brauchen eine klima
regierung und zweitens wir müssen
schauen den sozialen zusammenhalt in
diesem land zu stärken das heißt die
soziale ungleichheit darf sich nicht
weiter verschärfen sondern muss
verringert werden dafür braucht es eine
finanzpolitik die steuerpolitik und auch
eine politik sozialpolitik die nicht nur
im sinne eines kleinen teils der
gesellschaft der sehr viel hat
funktioniert sondern in der gesamten
gesellschaft
also ich habe verstanden dass auch auf
jeden fall natürlich klar zur stunde
noch vieles offen aber was wir im
vorfeld schon wussten es jetzt dass die
basis ihrer partei dieser jetzt
eigentlich wirklich er gegen jamaika
also würde die überhaupt mitmachen denn
das dann am ende ein mögliches eine
mögliche koalition sein könnte wie
wollen sie die überzeugen ich will ja
erst mal nicht mehr von gar nicht
überzeugen sondern ich will jetzt erst
mal schauen wo wir es meist rausholen
kann für klimaschutz und soziale
gerechtigkeit und das wird am ende auch
dass sein wonach unsere basis das
ergebnis beurteilen wird ich glaube wir
sehen dass wir ein programm partei sind
alles er inhaltlich orientierte partei
und am ende wird die basis fragen wo
können wir am meisten von unseren zielen
und von unseren projekten umsetzen aber
natürlich gibt es da die breite
erkenntnis auch an unsere basis dass wir
die größten schnittmengen mit der spd
haben in diesen bereichen und jetzt ist
es für sie natürlich vom ergebnis her
schon auch ein bisschen enttäuschend es
ist nicht so wie sie sich das mal vor
monaten vorgestellt haben warum ist das
denn am ende nicht besser gelaufen für
die gründe müssen wir schon noch mal
kurz darauf schauen denke ich ich glaube
man könnte sagen ist so ein bisschen wie
ein trauriger sieg oder vielleicht auch
ein etappensieg auf der einen seite ist
es das stärkste ergebnis dass wir als
grüne auf der anderen seite das muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen dass das was wir
uns als ziel gesetzt haben und vor allem
auch das was wahrscheinlich
gesellschaftlich möglich gewesen wäre
das konnten wir nicht realisieren wir
konnten die dynamik von beginn des
wahlkampfs nicht für uns dauerhaft
halten das lag bestimmt auch an eigenen
fehlern dass es dann zu einer duell
situation gekommen zwischen spd und cdu
das war für uns eine schwierige
ausgangslage trotzdem muss man sagen
unser wahlergebnis ist für uns ein
klarer regierungsauftrag und man kann
vielleicht sogar sagen der auftrag den
wir haben ist größer als dieses ergebnis
weil die klimakrise eben eine realität
ist vor der sich keine partei mehr
verstecken kann zum schluss noch die
frage an sie frau lang wie geht's ganz
konkret also heute weiter bei den grünen
was passiert jetzt als aller nächstes
jetzt als allerdings trifft sich um 10
uhr der bundesvorstand und dann werden
wir die weiteren strategischen schritte
sprechen dann vielen dank an dieser
stelle bis jetzt heute morgen ricarda
lang
wir machen nun weiter natürlich mit noch
mehr der analyse und wir schauen jetzt
jemand zusammen auf die wahlkreise wenn
das funktioniert auf meinem bildschirm
den ich gerne mit euch mitteilen und
zwar sehen wir hier also wie und ich
komme jetzt noch ein bisschen runter
damit man das besser sehen kann macht
das jemand größer das ist doch hier
sollte das funktionieren soll und wir
sehen also im süden ganz ganz viel union
und wir sehen hier eher im
nordöstlichen raum aber hier auch unten
natürlich hier auch rheinland-pfalz also
ganz viel spd und hier sehen wir aber
auch wo die afd am stärksten
abgeschnitten hat also hier zum beispiel
auch in sachsen da haben wir jetzt
natürlich noch gar nicht darauf geschaut
dass es aber auch hier sehr
bemerkenswert und jetzt wollen wir das
ganze was wir gehört und was wir gesehen
haben einordnen einschätzen mit
contender wenn natürlich unsere
stellvertretenden leiterin vom
hauptstadtstudio und allah du hast mit
gehört so richtig hat ja jetzt keiner
raus gelassen mit wem es wirklich machen
möchte aber was hattest du jetzt in den
gesprächen mitgenommen wo du gesagt hast
ja das war doch bemerkenswert also in
der mischung haben wir gesehen aus den
noten die ihr eingespielt hat und dem
was wir auch hier im studio gehört haben
dass sich tatsächlich immer noch alle
alle möglichkeiten offen halten also es
hat sich trotz der präferenzen die wir
kennen auf spd-seite hätte man natürlich
lieber eine ampel auf unions seite hätte
man lieber jamaika auch die fdp hat
immer gesagt wir wollen lieber jamaika
die grünen haben gesagt am will liegt
uns wahrscheinlich inhaltlich mehr trotz
all dieser bekannten präferenzen sind
jetzt wirklich alle bereit sich
anzuschauen wo kommen sie am besten
zusammen und wem passt das ergebnis am
ende am besten was ich jetzt wahnsinnig
interessant fand gerade war das was wir
hannes vogel noch mal erwähnt hat das
hat die fdp jetzt auch schon häufiger
gesagt diese dieses zusammenzählen von
stimmen also gemeinsam hätten fdp und
grüne mehr stimmen als spd oder union
das finde ich ein bisschen wacklig als
argumentation muss ich sagen weil wir ja
immerhin noch unterschiedliche
wählerinnen und wähler blöcke haben die
haben sich aus einem guten grund für
zwei verschiedene parteien entschieden
die auch in ihrer programmatik und auch
in ihrer thematik für sehr
unterschiedliche dinge gestanden haben
das ist schon sehr interessant zu sehen
wieder die argumentation jetzt läuft um
auch die eigene position zu stärken wenn
fdp und grüne erst einmal gemeinsam
überlegen was sie vielleicht miteinander
vereinbaren können oder wie sie
vielleicht miteinander zusammenarbeiten
können und dann in gespräche zu gehen
mit union und spd und wir wollen auch
mal ganz kurz hier gemeinsam auf die
kommentare von euch im stream schauen
und zwar schreibt anja horn hier bei
youtube ja natürlich wird es lange
dauern es ist ein desaster weil parteien
zusammen kommen die nicht
zusammengehören also möglicherweise und
dann haben wir hier auch noch mehr
meinung natürlich da gibt es auch immer
wieder jetzt die die darüber sprechen
wer ihr favorit war das ist ja ganz klar
dass da jeder auf seinen persönlichen
hat und hier schreibt zum beispiel
rosemann moni wieso wird nicht
akzeptiert was das volk gewählt hat ja
das ist jetzt ein bisschen die spannende
frage natürlich wer geht mit wem
zusammen und javi inwiefern
repräsentiert das dann auch am ende die
stimme der wählerinnen und wähler aber
es ist scheint noch wirklich alles offen
ich weiß nicht was kannst du absehen was
den fahrplan sein könnte jetzt für die
für die konkreten verhandlungen haben
wir es ja gehört dass sich erst einmal
fdp und grüne verständigen wollen ich
glaube